we played a game of ping pong
battleships where the goal is to pop all
of your opponent's balloons but you
can't see where they've placed them
first ones lose all their battleships
have to jump off a battleship
all right let's start building our
Battleship setups and each player has
three special battleships marked in a
different color and if you pop one you
get a hidden note that gives you an
advantage or a disadvantage
okay Emily ready yeah I'm ready
oh
oh no worries I still have eight left
whoa
sorry Mika
[Applause]
[Music]
I saw from your phone that he was really
close oh it was a complete poker face
there I'll just aim there at the same
place
oh I'm still waiting for my first pop
that was a blue one what's the special
rule out though
Mika sink your own battleship
[Applause]
how is that
I'll sacrifice I think I'll just pop
this one because it's the most annoying
one
oh no it's a queen
it doesn't pop for some reason then you
still get the point
what's my special
defend your battleships defend my
battleships there you go the rule is I
can defend the next two shots with this
magical weapon you're not coming over
here
oh
my turn yeah ready my defenses are up
hey
no goodbye balloon
[Music]
there we go why do I feel like I'm 100
gonna end up in the ocean after this
game
I agree
special ones
Shuffle move one balloon that's good
[Music]
hey guys I'm ready
oh it almost came back
[Music]
that was a special one okay let's see
what your love letter says ammo oh how
about that
this one's for you guys remember to hit
subscribe that's a nice love letter
Emily you got lucky this time it's not
sacrifice your balloon exactly
good try good try it's really close up
though thank you I remember that next
time yeah
[Music]
very nice nice
it's a way of hit
[Music]
oh again
we took it away so there's one ball
there oh no yes thank you
oh Special Rule
message says minimize
make one ball smaller that's probably
the best one so half size
do this one
[Music]
again so close yeah I know that's really
the sport you want to go for
[Music]
you're not going to reveal anything I'm
just looking directly in the eyes we
might just try to go for a jackpot
the table
I didn't hit the same spot anymore
changing tactics did good for you yeah
was it the special it's a special I hope
you get something terrible what is it
what is it what is it
no he got the airstrike whoa
okay unleash the airstrike I will
make a stuff
oh I think it was close that was very
close okay try to aim for that yeah
oh man you read it good advice good
advice good teamwork I saw from Otto's
eyes that he like blinked ah okay okay
the eyes are exposing things here
[Music]
the fishiness there is that a special
it's not a special
from your eyes
so there is another one like very close
to the one where I hit I'm gonna get my
sunglasses it's come to this they're
looking at my eyes all the time you're
like a poker player yeah this guy and
you see where I'm looking now Emma no
yeah
foreign
[Music]
it was special nice
we will one ball
we know where to go
[Music]
oh
[Music]
ammo gets the Mega Ball
here it is to make a bouncy ball I'll go
for officer
well at least two good bounce
that that was the ball you revealed yeah
now I'm gonna get that one that's over
there
[Laughter]
donate
donate well we all know you're not
getting your ammo Mika can I get one
ball time to say goodbye to my strongest
battleships I think he's gonna make it
to the end
[Music]
that's
just cheating
hello
that was a hit that was a hit
I feel like I have hit that same place
as well many times but it's it's not
there
yes I'm so happy for you it feels like
it's two versus one we gotta get you out
the game
clean here
I'm out I'm gonna get dumped into the
ocean but now I can see where you'll put
your food
please put your sunglasses on
that was very close
[Music]
thanks Tamika I at least have the one
left exactly I'm technically still in
the game oh so it's your balloon
[Music]
yeah
who will join me
yeah that was a yeah
it's so exciting
I've covered everything
you got it and where was it no it's
[Music]
you look like you're ready to do some
swimming one two three go
guys remember to hit subscribe if you
can see the Subscribe button here right
here
[Music]